GUNTHER ROLAND: OK.
What is really unique in Junior
Lab compared to any other class
that you could
think about teaching
is the breadth, both in terms
of the material, the techniques,
and the concepts that
you try to get across,
from the specific physics
of the experiments
to sort of general tools
of experimentalists,
both in terms of apparatus,
in terms of computing,
in terms of the
mathematical tools,
understanding systematic
uncertainties.
Then the communication
elements, from how
to write a paper, how to give a
talk, how to prepare a poster,
to sort of the very
general life skills,
like time management,
which really is critical
as you do this sequence
of experiments,
the collaboration
with their partners,
which is something that many
of them haven't experienced.
So Junior Lab really covers
many different aspects.
And one has to really think
about which are the ones
that one wants to emphasize
as a lecturer in the lab.
And I think it also is important
to really keep things fresh
and try to innovate
something every year--
a new experiment, new
elements-- just to really keep
the experience up to date.